I would say on average about once or
twice a week now I get a viewer in
YouTube usually on my main channel who
wants to debate me and tries to do so in
the comment stream oftentimes getting
quite upset and and sometimes saying you
know things that they probably should
should think through so I thought I
would create a video in this dr. Sadler
response series that is focused
specifically on why I think that debates
are probably not the most fruitful use
of my time and probably not your time so
if you're seeing this as a response it's
because you tried to debate me and and
at a certain point I said well you know
here's my standard response now I do
have a few things to say about this the
first of which is probably going to
strike people as being rather perhaps
mercenary and here I'm gonna be very
direct very frank in in what it is that
I have to say and I hope that people can
appreciate that part of it is the fact
that time is a limited commodity and my
time is indeed valuable so if you want
to debate me I generally don't do it for
free you know I'll say that one more
time I generally do not engage in debate
for free I do sometimes if there's a
really good reason but one person
feeling that it's a really good reason
or even a few other people weighing in
from from their particular tribe does
not make that so from where I sit so I
will quite often say I've given enough
time to this not going to do it now that
said if you want to engage in debate
with me
you can book a tutorial session like my
other clients do and you know you've got
me for an hour and and I'll debate with
you on whatever it is that you want I'm
probably not going to ultimately agree
with you but you'll probably learn some
in the process and who knows maybe
you'll decide you want to keep studying
some other stuff and the reason I have
to do that is because I only get 24
hours a day and it seems like with each
new year I am busier and busier I have
so many people making demands on my time
many of which you know are paying me for
for that and I have to do a good job
with all of my clients with the people
who I consult with with my students with
everybody else and I do do some pro bono
work right in a very few cases with with
clients you know where I think that that
it's really deserved or sometimes with
institutions I get free talks at
libraries and give about you know 30 a
year or so but when you know for the
most part the stuff that I do I actually
have to be compensated for it because I
do so much pro bono stuff I put out on
average now about two hundred and fifty
videos per year of new content I respond
to a lot of comments and I devote you
know a good portion of each day I would
say I probably devote between shooting
videos planning videos responding to
comments I probably devote anywhere the
average day from two to four hours to
that and that's you know that's a lot of
time so you know when you're thinking
about why isn't dr. Sadler willing to
engage on this particular topic with me
a you know a lot of it is a factor of
time and time well-spent you know I also
have to have enough time to work out to
live a healthy life to to devote to my
my wife and my children and my pets and
my family you know spread out in other
places and my friends and my community
all of that is is important so all of
that puts things into perspective I
think another thing that I'd like to say
as well is that you know I think that a
lot of people have this expectation
that if you're putting your content
there on YouTube somehow you made some
sort of contract with the viewer and if
they say something you have to respond
to them that's total BS if you know to
begin with comments I don't even have to
leave them on my channel if I want to
delete every single comment that people
put which I'm never gonna do that would
be perfectly within my rights as a not
only legal but moral rights as a Content
producer my channel is sort of like my
front porch and so if you're coming onto
my front porch and dr. Sattler dish you
know I'm wanting to argue with me I'll
kick you off my front porch because I
don't want you there oh if you have bad
things to say insert so you're swearing
at me I'm not gonna deal with you right
I'll just you know block you and delete
your comment because it's not it's not
worth it
I mean if you if you if you feel that I
owe to you to engage in debate when I'm
providing high quality video content for
free and I have been for what six years
now there's a kind of skewed perspective
going at and and where does this
perspective come from I think that the
biggest place other than a sense of
entitlement that that a lot of people
have is this metaphor that we we throw
around we talk about the marketplace of
ideas right and it's sort of like well
anybody who puts their idea out there
has to defend it has to be prepared to
defend it to the teeth no they don't
that's not the way the world works it's
only a metaphor and you know we don't
all have to defend everything all the
time as a matter of fact it's often
enough just to put the things out there
and and we've already made a major
contribution to whatever marketplace of
ideas you want to talk about and the
other thing to keep in mind is you know
if you if you view yourself as you know
a skeptic or a critic or somebody who's
doing yeoman's work in the marketplace
of ideas you better really know your
stuff right or else your
wasting again wasting everybody else's
time the marketplace of ideas works best
when we have exchanges between people
who really do understand the material
and have legitimate differences that can
then be brought to light it's not about
you know answering the same questions
over and over and over and over again at
the same basic level another thing to
keep in mind I think that that's quite
important is you know I know that
there's a lot of people who you know
shoot YouTube videos and they don't
really know what they're talking about
when it comes to philosophy I know that
because I I see their videos and
occasionally very very very occasionally
I'll comment and say well this is I
think they've got so-and-so wrong or I
think this this is not actually what
Aristotle is saying I'm not that way if
if I put something out there it's it's
because I've put in some time and done
some research some of the thinkers who
I'm presenting on I've been reading
since my teens or 20s and I've been
studying in a serious way for years and
years I've been teaching philosophy for
decades I've made solid contributions to
the field in terms of scholarship and in
terms of popular work you know if I if I
tell you that Nietzsche says X or that
that you know Hegel says X or Kant says
X probably they actually do there are
legitimate differences in interpretation
between scholars and and and experts but
you know those are usually carried out
in a sort of that well sometimes not but
usually kept a civil and respectful way
in which both both parties or multiple
parties acknowledge the expertise of the
other person so you know odds are if you
hear me saying something about Aristotle
and you don't think it's right and it
doesn't quite jibe with what you
read in this history of philosophy or
remember from your you know your class
that you took or what your favorite
professor said probably I actually know
what I'm talking about and there are
cases where I'm you know I'm wrong and
I'll admit it but that's not usually
going to come up through YouTube
comments
I do mispronounce things I do when I'm
writing things on the board misspelled
that's that's life right but that's
pretty pretty pretty small stuff and
that's and that's not even worth
debating about right so I'm a bad
speller the content is what matters so
you know the the last thing that I'm
gonna say about about debates because
you know before that here's here's the
other thing about time right if you're
trying to get me you know trying to show
me that I've got something wrong that's
probably not a good use of your time
because you may in fact you know hit the
bull's eye that one time but but most of
the time you're actually gonna have been
barking up the wrong tree
so the last thing that I'm gonna say
about debates is that you know when I
was an undergraduate and even a graduate
student I really did enjoy the agonistic
experience of getting in there and
scrapping and on all of that and I spent
a good portion of my life trying to get
past that I don't think that's a
particularly useful model for doing
philosophy well I understand that in
some schools they kind of teach that as
the the mo right and it does you know
appeal to certain kinds of people but
that's not how advances in philosophy
for the most part take place and it
doesn't matter whether you're talking
about you know Nietzsche
or you know Aristotle or Ansem or
whoever the temperament of the
philosopher doesn't necessarily dictate
the way in which we should go about
talking about them or debating about
them
so I tend to avoid debates if somebody
really wants to try to push it with me
you know my suggestion is book me for a
tutorial session and I'll be happy to do
that with you if it if it comes down to
the need for my debating some other
public figure on some topic my question
is gonna be a camp can't somebody else
do that there's so many other people out
there who love doing that sort of
activity and I would prefer to like you
know put stuff on the blackboard and get
stuff done with the time yeah but you
know if need be and I have to debate
somebody I suppose I will if it's for
the public good but if it's something
that you just want because you you know
you think that this is a way to improve
your understanding of of you know mock
Schaller or you know Jacques Lacan or
whoever yeah book my time you know show
me that it really is valuable to you and
I'll take you just as seriously as I do
my many other clients who book my time
because they think that it's it's worth
doing but if you don't want to do that
and then don't be surprised if when I
think you're trying to get me involved
in a debate I put this video oh because
frankly it's it's you know this is a
great time-saver for for me so that's
all I really have to say about this
topic